you need to have a clear mission and a
clear vision for your business to help
keep you on track and help keep you
motivated otherwise you're going to end
up running in a million different
directions staying on this treadmill
working really hard and not actually
getting anywhere hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today maintain a
question from one of my readers Roman
who wrote in to say thanks to the
efforts of the videos in addition how
can I develop a clear vision and mission
of my business or as an enterprise so
thanks for the question grant great
question you need to love what you do
and you need to know what it is that
makes you special and have a goal those
things keep you motivated because it's
hard getting up in the morning being an
entrepreneur you need to have something
that empowers you that makes you want to
get up and go do something so here are
mine and I'll show you my process with
you and hopefully that can help you
develop your mission your vision I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and you'll hear that at my
videos that's something that I believe
to my core if I break that down it
starts with entrepreneurs I love helping
entrepreneurs that is the core of what I
do if you are business owner if you want
to become an entrepreneur I can help you
if you're not an entrepreneur I probably
can help you it's so important I love
working with entrepreneurs I get
excitement for meeting entrepreneurs I
get excited by doing these videos
anything that is related to
entrepreneurship I love doing so that
has to be a core part of what I'm all
about
I added the word hungry in front of it
because I don't want to work with
entrepreneurs who don't really want it
too many people sit and say wow I could
make a business I should do that one day
you know maybe I'll take some time and
do it and they never do anything about
it
those aren't the guys I want to work
with those aren't the people that
inspire and motivate me that I want to
help if you're hungry if you really want
it if you're going after if you're
hustling and you're passionate I want to
help you the next one is deserve hungry
entrepreneurs deserve I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
because as hard being an entrepreneur
nobody's looking out for you you got to
do this yourself
and I remember how hard it was for me
and making $300 a month just trying to
survive and not be able to get through
and almost closing down my business I
wish I had somebody to help me get
through that and so that's what I try to
do I try to share those ideas and
resources and help people like you so
you have to figure out what it is that
you do when you say those words it means
something to you it's critical my own
vision my personal goal is I want to
help a billion entrepreneurs with my
website we've helped over 20 million
entrepreneurs already I want to get to
billions gonna take a long time but
through the videos through Twitter and
Facebook and the newsletter and all the
articles I'm writing all of that stuff
the TV shows the radio programs the
books all of that is helping
entrepreneurs I want to reach a billion
entrepreneurs that's a goal that
inspires me daily and you need to come
up with something yourself
for your business why are you starting
this it's great to want to make money
but there has to be something bigger I
want to make money and I'm making money
by helping entrepreneurs but the main
goal isn't money that doesn't inspire me
I'm not waking up every day saying hey I
want to make 100k today you have to
figure that out for your business so
think take some time get away from the
house you know go on vacation or go to a
coffee shop go to a library somewhere
quiet where you can relax and really
think about the keywords that have
meaning to you so for me it started with
entrepreneurs that's my audience so
who's your audience then think about how
you can narrow that down I don't want to
help all entrepreneurs I want to help
the hungry ones the guys who really are
going for it because those are the guys
who can really use help so how can you
narrow down your market and then what do
you believe in doing and for me I
believe that they deserve help I really
believe that those hungry entrepreneurs
we're trying to make a difference in
their lives and the lives of other
people they deserve how so what empowers
you what gets you excited and motivated
and once you figure that out then have
some big goal that you're shooting
towards and
in a world where the problem has been
solved and you can be a key component
than that so I want to reach a billion
entrepreneurs I hope I've helped a few
more through this video good luck Roman
thanks to the question for those of you
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below it makes you wanna
do more for you and here I want to hear
from you if you have a comment please
leave it in a comment section below if
you have a question for your business
leave it below
I love seeing those coming I love
answering your questions thank you guys
I'll see you soon